- Give me some room. I need
some room. Give me some space.
- Oh my God.
- What?
- Adele just released a new song.
- Oh no.
- I remember the first time
I heard "Someone Like You",
I cried for two hours.
Adele's music is so relatable and sad.
- Shh. Do you hear that?
(gasp)
- My God, it's already happening.
- Adele's music is too beautiful.
- The song is spreading
all over the internet.
(cries)
- We've got to protect people from
reflecting on their past heart breaks.
- (beep) yeah.
This is for making me
think about my ex-boyfriend
every time I hear "Rolling in the Deep".
- Whew. Hopefully nobody else here ah-
- Like, you gotta listen to this.
- No way. Her music is too emotional.
(dramatic music)
- Good job. Now let's
go save some more lives.
(sobs)
- Wait, sounds like
someone's sobbing in there.
(louder sobs)
- My cat just died.
- Oh, sorry about that.
(gasp)
- Alright, I'll rip off their
headphones, you go over-
- Mike, we don't have
time to stop everyone
from listening to Adele.
We've gotta get outta here.
(suspenseful music)
- Kaitlyn, wait.
- Why? What's wrong?
- We can't run forever.
Adele will never stop creating music
that makes us feel naked and scarred
and empowered, all at the same time.
Whether it's today,
tomorrow, or next week,
we're inevitably gonna hear her new song.
So let's face it, Adele can't be stopped.
- [Voiceover] And in other news,
the lack of rain in Los
Angeles is no longer a problem
thanks to all the tears
created by Adele's new song.
(crying and sobbing)